hello and welcome to the ASCAP and show
episode 3 where I'm answering your
questions to help you grow your business
let's jump in first question youtube you
are love you guys Tiger 80 I hey Evan
can you help me what type of skills
should I look for in a co-founder to
start a web two point O startup I put in
my checks zero skills to start a tech
company so I've been wondering who I
should recruit I'll second of aux
front-end coder or should I go for a
full web developer do most web
developers also know bit of UX is one
partner enough as a team of three to
credit any of the skills that you look
for hey this is a great question and and
I love it because I get so many people
who write in whoo-hoo ask your questions
on youtube on my radio show who are the
business person and they have zero tech
skills and you want to start a tech
company if you want to have success if
you look at the tech companies look at
any tech companies achieve rapid success
look at who the founders are you always
have somebody on the team who's the tech
guy who's the tech genius to get all the
stuff done so you can't just hire that
out if you want to build a successful
technology company you gotta have
somebody on your team who loves the
technology side so I love that you
understand your weakness here and you're
trying to find it up with partnerships
you got to make sure it's the right one
right you got to find the right person
who not only has the skills you need but
also fits from a personality and a
values point of view this is like
getting married and so many people jump
into partnerships because it makes sense
on the skills looks good on paper and
everybody's happy at the beginning
everything is working and you're trying
to crunch out a product but when things
get tough how are you going to handle it
that's where partnerships tend to fall
apart and so I would start with one
person if you don't know these guys yet
I would start with one person find them
like really do your homework to find
that right person work together on a
small project first see how well you
guys are going along before making
decision to get married you're dating
before you're getting married find that
one person is a tech person partner up
with your business skills and launched
the company take it from there okay next
up remark hey there Evan I very much
like the videos was wondering 15
your video about outsourcing please
include your top five websites for that
outsourcing so this is great i love
outsourcing i think as an entrepreneur
if you want to have success you need to
focus on what you do great what you're
awesome at and get rid of everything
else eliminate automate and delegate so
that we're focusing on what i call CEO
time as much as possible the big picture
stuff to help you grow your business so
outsourced is an awesome way to do it my
favorite single outsource web site is
odesk i found a lot of great people on
odesk I've listed a number of videos on
how to have success with odesk I'm used
odd esta higher Christina obviously my
video producer here marketers virtual
assistant programmers I love odesk I'm a
huge fan but you got to make sure you're
doing it right so that's my number one
for sure resource for outsourcing apart
from that I've done some things on fiber
some things for business some things for
fun where people will do things for five
bucks it's interesting to see what
people do for five bucks I use it mostly
for fun stuff that relates to my
business I had Morgan Freeman prank call
my agent and a couple other people but
I've use it for business to where I've
had my videos for example is YouTube
videos transcribe and somebody will do
up to think of 16 minutes of audio for
five bucks and so there's some
opportunities for business just make
sure that it kind of fits with with what
you need apart from that I've looked at
I've used what else in the news i've
used nanny I designs great resource for
anything graphic design related where
you can post a project and people from
around the world good on it and so if
you're looking for graphic design work
that's my favorite place to go to I
think that's it I've tried a lot of
different sites a lot of different
services i'm trying to think of things
that i would feel comfortable
recommending to you those would be my
three yes 45 and giving you three but
the three our goal so odesk fiber 9am
designs but really odesk place to be
okay up next Jovana Oh Havana Milanovich
Milanovic me me
Jean ovitch okay yovanna I want you to
make a video to tell me how to pronounce
her name because I probably butchered it
anyway great question Sheridan to say
can you share your food for thought on
the food habits of a healthy
entrepreneur haha this is a great
question and a lot of entrepreneurs are
not healthy you know you're working
crazy hours here you're stressed out
you're working 80 hours a week 100 hours
a week you're putting everything you got
into this and it can be hard to look
after yourself well from a food
perspective as well as a health fitness
just general well-being and this
happened to me you know I went on a
cruise on a king Bach and and I didn't
have the greatest eating habits I wasn't
massillon for a wait okay you see my
videos I'm not like I'm not putting on
the pounds here but taught it scared me
that when I got on the cruise ship about
halfway through I was over 200 pounds
which for me is a lot i was i was a buck
60 when I got to university and 180 185
has been kind of my typical wait the
200-plus that for me was like a huge
shock about I haven't changed something
and a couple of things that helped with
my good eating habits 01 lentils in the
morning so every morning I have lentils
and I have some spinach arugula on top
and it fills you up it's super healthy
gives you lots of fiber and way better
for you than going for a bowl of cereal
then I have a smoothie and my wife makes
these amazing smoothies for me I try to
make it myself but as as Nina can
testify mine aren't very good I'm not a
good smoothie maker maybe I can learn
actually Nina has a great video on it
Christina put that video up in there
Nina makes a great smoothie recipe that
you guys can follow along and maybe I
should follow along to see how to do it
I don't know something to think about
from there I've been trying to cut down
on processed foods I'll there's all the
stuff that you hear right I'll like all
the all the basic usual stuff that you
hear right I don't need a lot of me I
don't need in processed foods and sugar
I drink a lot of water with lemon
what I got going on right here yummy
i'll try to have I don't know lots of
these glasses every day and I had the
one cheat day so that's for coming from
the tim ferriss for our body the one
cheat days usually saturday we'll go out
and eat whatever you know I might make
bacon and eggs in the morning and then
we'll go to get a huge sugary drink and
then a junkie lodge and then chips and
and junky dinner in the desert and yet
by the end of it actually by the end it
but I'm so so full of crap on a Saturday
that for the next you know four or five
days I don't want to see crap anymore
because I've had too much of it saatchi
works that well on top of that healthy
lifestyle you know do something to get
out of the office to get out of your
guests to move around I used to stand up
desk that your legs don't shut off and
I'm sitting here at a table but
typically I'm standing up I'll do
dancing salsa 20 25 hours a week and so
find something that you love to do that
gives you energetic and and you bring
that to your business when you are
energetic when you're helping your
business would be a lot healthier as
well all right next up Rio coussin who
writes in this a chasing your dreams
wider than have in your dreams trace you
but what more paralyzing and obstacle
than sheer fear how do you find not
simply the courage to stop being afraid
to stop doubting you can get there and
change the world at least in your own
way without having to fear you're not
good enough to know you're it to know
you're every bit of potential burning
inside you wait to be ignited how do you
go without obstacle and set the world on
fire it is an awesome question and I
think as entrepreneurs we go through
these phases where we are excited
passionate ready to go out and change
the world believe in and you're
believing in yourself knowing that yeah
today's a day i'm awesome i can do it
and then the next thing you wake up in
your you're starting all over again and
you dealt yourself and you're afraid and
you don't think you can do it you think
who am i I'm not good enough I don't
have experience and it's a constant
constant roller coaster and you guide
your entrepreneur you know what I'm
talking about even if you want to admit
it to anybody else you don't talk about
it you know
talking about and every entrepreneur
thinks about putting that sometime
multiple times in their life so you're
not alone if you're going through that
right now how do you keep it going so
here's the thing here's what helps me
what is you create a routine you gotta
have a routine you now have a morning
routine that sets you up for success
right at the start of the day I've
talked about a few times in the videos
that I've have you need to have music
that gets you excited bobbin moving get
you feeling it songs that inspire you
you got to have something that you watch
read consume that lifts you up that
builds you up that gives you confidence
for me I might watch me on Eric Thomas
videos I love reading my comments from
you guys will always inspire me and they
can feel like I think I should go I
gotta go do more I gotta go help more
people so you gotta have something in
the morning you put the music on while
you're making your breakfast and then
you have some tasks that gets you set up
for the day and you schedule that you
create an environment that supports you
because most of us have these
environments that don't support us that
you wake up and the media that you
consume when the friends you hang out
with and and your daily routine it
doesn't support big thinking breaking
through setting the world on fire right
what are you do on your daily routine
that makes you want to set the world on
fire create that environment you have a
choice you've been designed that for
yourself okay so that's one getting that
routine the second thing I want to talk
about is sometimes when you have the big
goal it looks like it's insurmountable
sometimes you look at this yeah i'm
going through that yeah i'm going to hit
that mountain across that I'm going to
knock down that castle whatever it is
you know like I'm gonna go for that goal
and other times you look at it and it's
too it's too big too scary too daunting
and what I found really helps is
breaking that down on the smaller steps
and doing things that scare you a little
bit but in steps so that big step today
seems like it's too big maybe tomorrow
or maybe yesterday that was that was no
problem but today it's too big take a
smaller step take a smaller step ticket
smaller stuff on the story like to tell
is when one of my first speaking gigs
that I had was in Brunei in Asia and
they asked me to come I just sold my
company that's going to come and speak
to them and share my you know expertise
whatever advice for entrepreneurs and I
was scared to do it I was scared this is
my first big speech it was going to be
broadcast on live
television there there were you know
thousand people in the room whatever it
was I was freaking out and I kind of
secretly wished that they would call me
up and say heaven it's off uh whatever
reason right I was hoping that would
happen but they didn't so I went and I
knew it was awesome and and I was scared
to do it and I did it anyways and now
doing that again is easy right I could
do that again if you put me in madison
square gardens with tens and tens and
tens of thousand people i probably a
little scared the first time I did it
but that I could do it again and so if
you're afraid that whatever next step
you want to take make it small make it a
little bit easier make it a little less
scary do it and then you could do that
again and you can go to the next one and
do that again and soul to you make your
your your weight up as you keep
conquering these little goals you become
less fearful more successful and you're
not just sitting there doing nothing
because sometimes when you look at that
big go on your down here the guide is
way too big I can't do it on nothing i'm
not gonna be able to do it and you and
you do nothing as a result so small
steps as you take those small steps
you'll become a lot more courageous and
what you do it want is easy to do again
great question okay last step today is
Jackie sue who's been a huge trying to
channel for a while supports me on
patreon Thank You Jackie Christine let's
pop the patreon link up here for those
of you who are fans thank you so much
appreciated he has a three-part question
that relates to legal work and so it's
ready to say as I feel my explanations
are too scattered here's a summary of my
points one will it be any law approach
in forming partnerships with other
companies such as contracts or is it
just a verbally mutual agreement to help
each other lots of ways to skin a cat
here you can form an official
partnership or somebody owns a piece of
your company or another company owns a
piece of your company detecting equity
in your in your business or you can just
have a verbal arrangement if you're
doing a marketing arrangement where
they're helping to support you your
upper to support them you don't
necessarily need a contract if they're
getting a commission of they're getting
a cut of everything that you sell then
then yeah then you want
contract written down so you don't come
back and Lady this AJ well you said
forty percent but why you giving me only
twenty percent right so you wanna if
there are specific rules that you're
laying out you want to have it written
down so just depends on the arrangement
you're setting up but if you're doing a
formal arrangement and formal
partnership either as a supplier or a
commission agent or equity investor in
your business and you want to have it
written down number two can a sole
trader business from partnership with
other companies and still remain as a
sole trader so again the partnership
here depends on what you're giving up
you know maybe you're giving up a piece
of your company in which case you're not
going to be a solo entrepreneur anymore
you can't be sole proprietorship maybe
you're just giving up a commission for
everything that they sell for you you
know they if they sell a hundred
products of yours and you're givin em a
twenty five percent commission then they
don't own a piece of your company you're
still a sole proprietor but you're
giving out that twenty percent just in
sales commission so again just depends
on the nature that you want to set up a
number three once at home a partnership
with a particular company let's say a
graphic designer does that mean I can
never work with other companies that are
also graphic designers and again here
totally flexible depends on what you
right into the agreement you can form an
exclusive arrangement with a company in
which case you won't be able to work
with other people but typically if
that's going to happen there's going to
be a premium in the contract so as an
example when I had my first software
company I would form international
partnerships of people to sell my
software and some of them i would have
an exclusive arrangement with where if
you're going to be my seller in japan i
would only sell through you i would not
part with anybody else any leads that i
got from japan i would send to you so
you can make all the money from it but
they had to pay me for that break
because exclusive is a lot more
exclusive right it's a lot more special
it's a lot more risky put in all in one
person and so depends on what you write
up so you can write in see you're
getting a graphic design firm to work
with you can write to say you are the
come i'm going to work with but there
should be something coming back to you
for giving up that right otherwise you
keep it open you don't say that this is
the only way to do it then we great
questions thank you guys so much for
watching episode 3 the ice Kevin show
let me know what you think ask the
question below if you haven't for me you
could be on the next episode and believe
subscribe to the channel if you want to
see more thank you guys so much for
watching I'll see you soon if you want
more believe energy running through your
veins sign up for the newsletter below
it's free you're gonna love it hi i'm
jason j reyez fonseka of ra's online com
and i want to say Evan Carmichael's
newsletter is consistent fun inspiring
and XD only newsletter i prioritize and
look forward to period